hey folks welcome to a very special
episode of now playing i'm your host
daniel dwyer and if you know me on the
internet you know i like playing first
person shooters especially 90s style
arena battle first person shooters and i
also like a good single player campaign
as well so i'm very uh happy to be
joined by two of the creatives behind
doom straight up just call doom 2016. uh
marty sir how you doing i'm doing great
good to see your ep on the project yes
sir uh you've been i did for a little
while now yeah you worked on quake live
and i did yeah i've been around it since
uh 2000 so about 16 years worked on uh
kind of even worked on id games before i
was at activision before that so uh um
yeah i've been around eight games pretty
much my whole career worked on quick
live and and uh have this great
opportunity yeah it's a big project to
sort of take to take the reins on
absolutely and hugo same for yourself as
well you've been working video games for
a while yeah you're at naughty dog as
well but recently you worked with
guillermo del toro on pacific rim as
well correctly i did yeah a little bit
of film and games and some animation
stuff commercials and different places
blur studios so excellent and what's
your role on the doom project what are
you i'm the creative director
excellent so you guys are tasked with
bringing this beast back to life yeah
that's right uh 2004 i guess yeah yeah
yeah yeah
it was the last yeah great year for
first-person shooters half-life 2 came
out that year yeah absolutely yeah and
we're getting back into it now some
really good fps's coming out this year
overwatch dooms in our game a lot of
people excited about the beta as well
you guys had last month um last week
last week it was a really god it was
that that recently yeah um how what was
the feedback from that well how do you
guys feel about it i feel like with a
game like doom you're always going to
appeal to a certain group but if you
appeal to them you're always going to
irk another group so how what was the
reception like yeah you know it's it's
uh
overall we were really happy with the
reception we got
just a ton of people playing a ton of
matches uh you know
thousands and thousands of matches um
you know big big for us is making sure
that the systems all all work on the
back end at least from a development
perspective you know you always hope
that uh that the servers stand up and
nothing fails and and all the
matchmaking we do with first party works
really well and that was that was
about as flawless as we could have could
have hoped so uh everybody got to play
um
and have a and have a really good time
and like you said you know there's
there's uh
feedback there was uh some some uh some
feedback we got from uh mainly the pc
community uh they they uh you know they
talked about was kind of all over the
place but talked about you know settings
gameplay settings that that uh that we
had we
added a advanced settings um uh box that
uh that you know they wanted a little
bit more information on so we released
that and we're gonna be doing a series
of tech articles that really dive into
all of the all of the things that you
can do with the game got to have that
fov slider exactly actually we have an
fov slider even in the console version
which is kind of unheard of and and
really pretty cool um and then and then
gameplay wise you know we we really it
we get feedback from you know just about
the entire spectrum yeah um
we went into it very much with a uh a
feeling that uh that doom is uh
on the multiplayer side it was when
you're talking about making a game for
for 2016 a little bit more of a
a blank slate for us i think than than
uh than even the the the single-player
side um so we really tried to to do what
we've done throughout the project which
is kind of be inspired by by the the
types of things that you you do in in
doom and the things that that are fun
and and exciting and the kind of water
cooler moments of doom but bring them
bring them forward make it make a make a
modern experience out of it make it
something that even if you've never
played doom before uh you can have a lot
of fun with and and really enjoy but if
you've if you've played it before it
there's a familiarity to it um so uh
yeah so we we really uh we we played a
ton internally we love it we have a have
a ton of fun with it um and uh and you
know i think by and large a lot of
people had fun with debate yeah certain
affinity did a good amount of work on
that as well yeah we worked with them as
a as a partner um they've been involved
in the project for a number of years as
well um you know we have a we have a
small team of multiplayer uh developers
internally we manage it all direct at
all um and then uh and then they have a
great team uh as as well there that uh
they have
they have a good bit of experience with
uh uh with with multiplayer map
development they've done it on on
several projects and and we really had a
great great working relationship with
those guys their their talented team
yeah i could i could talk about the
multiplayer in that for i did a live
stream of it last week like i i went
back and played
one doing one two and three recently and
i'm a massive quake fan yeah um and it
for me it felt like not it felt
different in so many ways and it was
ways that i especially when i saw
gameplay but i really wasn't sure but
actually when i got into it the flow of
it i felt really good but we could talk
about multiplayer all day i don't want
to talk about any more multiplayer
because you guys are here with the
single player yeah it is important to
note with it that that beta was just
kind of the tip of the iceberg you know
it was it was a beta like there's
there's a lot more guns there's a lot
more uh armor sets there's you know
we've got tons of modes uh levels yeah
way different levels so uh so you know
if you if you played it you loved it you
play it you you were you were still on
the fence about it you know i would i
would encourage anybody just to to pick
it up uh and again the multiplayer is
just a just a small sliver of it we got
we got snapmap and we've got obviously
what we're showing today with camtasia
you guys pretty close to release any
more multiplayer betas before no i think
we're done that's done with multiplayer
based yeah we're on the cusp of shipping
so sweet yeah i know may 13 right yeah
super close last piece of housekeeping
on this bad boy if you're watching live
we have some sweet schwag to give away
uh everyone's favorite the cyber demon
right here is signed by our two
prestigious guests right here hugo and
marty you can win this bad boy you can
also win uh one of i think 10 other
little prizes we have
doom branded swag little um i'm not sure
if they're also cyber demons but they're
little models uh to win that retweet the
gamespot thing that we done tweeted
earlier make sure you're following us so
we can give you get your address um i am
very much under the assumption that this
is north america only apologies to all
my irish brethren you'll have to check
that out on a different live stream all
right let's dive into it uh doom check
it out yeah absolutely so this this is
uh we're starting at a
in a facility a uac facility called the
resource operations center um
and uh and really this is this is the
second um mission in the in the game
you've kind of woken up uh and uh and
made your way out of a kind of a top
secret bunker you really have no idea
why you're there and everything's going
fine yeah and and everything is not
going fine
there's been a massive demonic invasion
um and you make your way across the
martian surface uh and end up here uh
you're you're here to
to re-establish some some communication
so you can figure out what has happened
um i i'll talk about a few things and
then kind of let the gameplay speak for
itself you're noticing uh you know kind
of these orange highlights that appear
um those are what we call glory kill
highlights love the blood um oh nice
touch pads doom 3 throw back there yeah
exactly
and
those are those are glory kill
highlights we uh when you when you do a
certain amount of damage um to uh to an
enemy uh it allows you to to put them in
this state where you can they're kind of
stunned and you can go up and do a
a
kind of a fantastic melee kill execution
on them or you can you can you can shoot
them and you use them strategically as
you play as well yeah is there any
what's the benefits of that apart from
the sort of aesthetic
you actually uh you get you get extra
health and ammo uh from them uh so that
there's a kind of a gameplay perspective
um
that you're kind of looting them
whatsoever yeah i mean it's it's it's
funny in our game you know you don't you
don't stop to regenerate health you pick
it up in the world here you just just
found a secret by by finding the auto
map station and and activating it
realizing there's something above him um
but uh but yeah so there's the gameplay
benefit of kind of stopping them
the the combat is just it's it's you
know sometimes overwhelming so being
able to to stagger a guy and stop him
and know that he's not going to move for
a few minutes even if you don't glory
kill him or you you decide you know i'm
gonna i'm gonna take him out with guns
um
it's it's a it's a huge gameplay benefit
again this is pretty early so we're just
kind of ramping the player up to some of
the some of the mechanics and some of
the the ideas that are that are
different than uh than a lot of uh other
um a lot of other games right now yeah
right at the gauge you know there's some
nice little you know throwbacks
to like obviously the doing three kind
of esque menus the the map there was
very much sort of like old 90s doom
style
the pace of this though this is very
much more like classic dooms than
opposed to something like doom 3 which
would be the the closest graphical uh
in terms of like
the relationship between these games
yeah yeah and as you see as we as we get
further in it gets it gets really fast
so here you know you can use the autumn
map to figure out there's some there's
some armor up there so you find your way
up but a lot of you know doom's always
another big part of doom is exploration
so um you know when he pulls that up you
can see like the number of secrets alone
that are in this in this map i think
there's like nine or something like that
um and and actually we're gonna we're
gonna show here as he plays through um
there's there's kind of a
straightforward way to play through and
then and then you know for players who
really want to look around they want 100
the level they want to find all the
upgrade uh possibilities uh you really
can this is this is actually again we're
kind of introducing the player to to the
types of uh to the types of feel uh
gameplay feel things that you get
throughout the game um this is fairly
flat but uh um but you get the idea like
i'm surrounded by by enemies and you're
you're constantly pushing forward if you
get hurt
you kind of charge in and take a guy out
so you can gain some health uh how many
different types of the zombies are there
then how many like subclasses are you
calling yeah there's there's a few um
you kind of kill them fast fast enough
to
so fast you don't really don't even
realize that guy's taking a beating
yeah those helified soldiers are really
cool there's a there's a few versions of
those as well as shoot different you'll
notice uh you know kind of very very
important aspect of doom is the fact
that most of the uh
most of the enemies attacks are are
projectiles right um so uh and you're
you're often faster than the enemies and
faster than the projectile so the the
mechanic of weaving in and out of
projectiles as they're flying towards
you and dodging them and and using your
movement as a as a defense uh is a
massive uh massive massive part of the
game yeah but yeah big aspect of the the
game historically
for sure uh
let's uh let's let the game breathe for
a little while i just want to sit back
because i know there's a bunch of people
watching [ __ ] on the live stream nice to
just sort of uh crank up the volume and
chat here at the uac we take pride in
nurturing a growing workforce and each
year we harvest only the best of the
best are you ready to move up to take on
new challenges to become more than you
ever dreamed you could be talk to your
supervisor to see if you meet the
requirements for this year's sole artist
try to figure out that or or decide to
skip
yeah i guess traversal has always been a
part of well sorry exploration has
always been a part of doing traversal
not really i mean you're talking about
the first doom you couldn't even that
you know mouse look what's happening
that came later or jumped yeah you're
jumping exactly
oh here we go
yes
the chainsaw is uh obviously just a ton
of fun to use but um but it also has
distinct gameplay uh advantage actually
why don't you
after this we can
turn those yeah
we can turn those off the the tutorials
keep popping up this is actually uh um
a good
good little example of uh you know the
types of things you can you can
kind of customize the the play so you
can you can turn off the hud you can
turn off the compass you can turn off
the glory kill highlights if you just
want to play like strip down all i see
is my gun
you can do that on the console you can
change the field of view which is which
is kind of unheard of how does it go um
110
yeah it's really uh
120s well that's for
90 is the lowest it goes yeah 90 is the
default um this isn't quite three we're
playing here that's right um
but the chainsaw uh has some pretty
distinct gameplay advantages um you can
see when he picked it up it added his
his uh chainsaw fuel in the bottom right
there underneath the gun the little red
markers oh so there is a there's a
an ammunition for the champion
yeah and and um
the the uh the bigger the enemy the more
ammunition or the more fuel it takes to
kill him so uh uh so you're kind of when
you when you use the chainsaw on an
enemy it dumps a massive amount of ammo
um and so you're always kind of making
this decision about do i want the one
hit kill
against an enemy like a bigger enemy you
know you may use all your fuel to take
them down right and get that one ammo
dump or you can save it and use it you
know multiple times on smaller enemies
um
and and kind of have that more uh
constant replenishment of ammo how much
weapon weapon cycling do you sort of
think gamers will be doing a lot yeah
because that's kind of like you do it
constantly yeah yeah this is this is
this is pretty early we try to you know
we try to ramp the player up uh again
with with the experience um you know at
this point in the game you pretty much
have the the shock on the combat shotgun
and the pistol um but
but as they so so it's it's kind of all
about introducing the concept of these
combat arenas the the movement the
mantling constantly moving forward and
not having to worry too much about
weapon switching but then as you pick up
the weapons
you end up you know you end up carrying
them all with you plus all your mods
that you pick up your gun mods so you
end up with about 20-ish types of
gun things that you can you can shoot
with um when you when you factor in all
the mods um
another just great examples of secrets
we'll kind of come back to that
um
and then and then we get them into into
kind of spaces like this you've heard us
probably refer to these things as like
skate parks and when you kind of look at
them from that perspective you can kind
of see how this this feels like a place
that you would just want to
run through and and flow through yeah is
that the the idea is to keep like sort
of forward forward momentum for the
player yeah absolutely always giving
them a space this is this is kind of
early these these these enemies are kind
of protecting this gore nest and then uh
when you actually uh
the demons build these and when you when
you go in to take it out uh it kind of
summons a last stand of enemies around
it so it makes it makes it this really
fun moment of kicking off a a massive
battle you know so this that's the gore
nest yeah this is a good one just to
kind of sit back and and enjoy the enjoy
the show
so
it's nothing like
you saw there a couple things uh uh this
gun
this combat shotgun actually has a
couple mods on it hugo's been using the
the uh explosive shot mod um and the way
the mods work is you you find them uh in
the world that uh these uh supply drones
um walk up to them and scans your
inventory and figures out which ones
that you you can you can
which ones are available which guns
you're carrying and then gives you uh a
choice of of mods so you you really get
a a a broad choice uh of how you
approach the gameplay is it a single mod
for weapon there's two two mods for most
weapons a gun like the uh super shotgun
only doesn't have any mods but single
mod slot classic um yeah you actually
you you you care if you've got both mods
you carry both mods and you can hot swap
between them so uh here he just he just
switched to well he switched back to the
uh the um the
explosive shot um but the other mod for
this gun is a triple burst and those are
activated all with the left trigger so
you know no real aim down sight uh the
the left triggers used um for um for for
mod capabilities on the guns
absolutely yeah so this is this is a
supply drone right here he happens to
have both mods all he has right now is
the the pistol and the shotgun um but
that's how you can uh get those uh
interesting time for it properties i
mean machine games did a fantastic job
with walton slim in the order yeah
absolutely i don't think anyone expected
that to be i mean you could very easily
say with a straight face that that might
be the best wolfenstein game i mean yes
certainly like
one of the best first person shooters
come out in a couple years how did i
feel
with it internally like having this game
sort of get get worked on and do really
do really well and be like well received
by gamers around the world do you have
that sort of i know do must have its own
responsibility already but were you sort
of even more sort of inspired to do well
because of what they did oh yeah
absolutely i mean we're really close to
the sheen game guys we share technology
and and kind of all throughout that they
they brought their own uh look at the
secret now that's really cool
um
so uh so he's gonna he's gonna go back
and and actually so he could come he
i'll talk about the machine games guys
in a second but uh he uh he uh he he's
he's basically gotten to a level you
know he got the yellow key but if if you
noticed earlier there's a couple little
uh so if you don't want any spoilers on
how to find secrets maybe you can
turn away or something you'll probably
have forgotten in three weeks that's
right um but you can actually go back
and and if you remember he saw a door uh
that that that also could use the yellow
key oh yeah it was kind of locked it
it has a security panel in it that locks
down some other hatches um
all of the all of the weapons uh you can
find in an earlier level so um if you
want to you know if you really want to
dive in and explore for secrets there's
just there's just some really cool stuff
that you can find you can actually you
know find upgrades earlier and that kind
of thing so you know here he's kind of
dove into a secret um but yeah the uh
you know as far as wolfenstein uh yeah i
think they did uh they did they just did
an awesome job with it and uh uh and you
know it's
it's it's great to be you know we we get
to work with machine games um we get to
uh you know we're kind of sister studios
with bethesda game studios yeah and you
know almost everything they do is super
inspiring so um so it's really it's
really fun it's it's uh it
it
it just drives everybody to do uh more
and more uh and even better work um
so this this right here is actually a
prater suit upgrade screen um he just
got that that uh um that chip out of the
elite guard um and finding those uh
totally exploration based um finding
those lets you upgrade your suit to do
um
to do uh all different kinds of
increased abilities this is the this is
the secret pickup for the plasma gun so
nice most players is you know when they
play through the first time or if they
haven't been fortunate enough to watch
this stream um they won't even know this
is here but if you if you really dive in
you look around uh look for your secrets
um
and then this secret actually just
continues you can you can kind of
continue on and and uh and find even
more stuff but we can uh
yeah either way
any any gun pickups that then you know
15 monster closet open up the minute you
there's there's a few little surprises
like that yeah um that was kind of a
thing in doom three you know yeah you
picked up something and and there was
there was a it's a floor it's a classic
yeah yeah um you see that a little bit
more in in hell uh on some of our levels
that's there's there's a lot of uh if
you've if you've played a lot of doom i
think um when you get into the hell
levels this is actually kind of a super
secret within a secret if you if you
actually skip the mod drone um and then
you find the gun that you uh from the
secret you can come back and it
recognizes that you've picked it up so
now you get to you get to pick a mod
here for the heavy assault rifle you get
the mod by punching the drone you do yes
he's very aggressive he's he has uh new
marine has no patience he has no
patience for anything he just wants to
destroy things we're going to show or
sorry you guys are going to show um a
bunch of other parts of the game as well
so for folks who are asking about um
mars and or sorry hell and beyond you're
going to oh yeah oh absolutely yeah we
got we've got a few sections to show
this is we're showing about yeah this is
actually out on the surface of of mars
right outside of this facility um you
get a sense of kind of what the what the
outdoors is like yeah let's sit back and
have a little a little watch
this is
so
it's a good little power-up a lot of
times you'll you'll enter a space and
actually
see a power-up and decide you know i
don't want to pick that up quite yet
because i you know maybe i've got a lot
of health or you know i feel like i can
control the combat and just wait until
the moment where i've lost control of
the combat before i actually pick it up
so one of the great things that you sort
of always did historically and you're
seeing a little bit of it here i guess
with the different types of zombies is
having that
enemy variety and like having to pick
and choose who you take on
yeah absolutely i think you'll get a
good sense of that as we as we jump
ahead and uh and and show some some
other stuff um actually we'll probably
we can do that now yeah i know we kind
of cleared that outdoor area um
yeah it's it that that that we call it
uh
when we're talking about it internally
and we're and we're um uh uh
you know talking about the way we want
gameplay to feel it's always about like
this this kind of chess board feel of of
things where each enemy is very
distinctive um the arenas the the combat
spaces are are built specifically for
combat they're not you know
we try to we try to make sure they stay
grounded in a reality of visuals and and
that kind of thing but you know uh yeah
um but you uh
but it's really very much about gameplay
and movement and and kind of the
fluidity and giving you opportunities to
to jump down and go get up and mantle
and giving the the demons uh
opportunities to to kind of use the
environment similarly you saw imps that
would crawl up the you know the walls or
crawl up the pillars and fire from up
above where did that impetus to have
that type of movement come from because
it's i mean do one and two were very
fast games yeah but they weren't games
where you were you know obviously we
talked already about the freedom jump
button as well yeah and then even doom
three probably suffered from the
opposite of what you're talking about
which is that it almost felt too
grounded and then the combat in that
game was a little bit restricted by the
sort of how real the the base was yeah
so where did you guys come from the
angle of like oh we're going to make
this doom game we're going to make it
where you're like mantling and jumping
and spinning fast and because
to me as a layman that seems more like
quake almost that type of gameplay yeah
i mean
i i guess you're you're always kind of a
product of of the influences of the past
so you know i mean there's a lot of us
have played a lot of quake and there is
that kind of
fluidity of movement and pace of
movement that's fun um when we started
uh early kind of pre-production
development on this uh
we were just doing a lot of prototyping
of stuff and we knew we wanted you know
movement was key and and um and so some
some of the early prototypes were with
things like double jump mechanics and
mantling and the the i i suppose the
underlying kind of element of all of it
was uh was just the the pace and the
fluidity of of of movement and you know
you kind of
we have these big structures the uac and
and hell i mean you you kind of have
this
massive scope to it uh and uh and to be
able to to climb through it and and have
that be a uh uh
a major part of it just it just it just
fit kind of kind of early on and we've
done some early prototypes where it
worked really well so that that was kind
of the i think the the
it was it was really you know kind of
along with the glory kills some of the
some of the early
gameplay iteration that we did and and
trying just a bunch of different things
in a prototype state that really it just
it just fit fit well with with how we
wanted to approach gameplay yeah you're
going to show another little yeah
actually we're going to jump into uh
lazarus labs um this is uh a little more
than halfway through the game um and is
is really um part of
uh
we've taken a step with the the uac um
where we've really tried to to kind of
give them a
level of depth um and uh and kind of
character that is uh that i think is is
is cool um and uh and and deepens the
lore and the mystery around them and and
starts to explain things like why they
were experimenting on demons and
why that would even be somewhat
acceptable yeah like we put this
tragically quest to the back of a
revenant um
we'll show here
this is obviously further in the game so
you have much more many more weapons and
uh and uh mods uh for those guns so here
hugo's upgrading his explosive shot we
we normally you don't get to this place
in the game and you don't have 33 uh
upgrade points
we're just doing that from uh just just
so we can show you some of this stuff um
uh here the you know he's upgrading the
heat blast mod um improved venting um
with all of our you know at a
fundamental level um all of the mods and
all of the upgrades really are are
elements that uh you know that do
significant change to the to the to the
gun um it's not just like a five percent
upgrade that you work for it's it's
really something significant um and i
think as people dive in and play it we
don't spend too much time on the menus
here but uh um
you know here he's he's upgrading uh his
environmental resistance uh this is more
related to your person um so you can see
things like if you're uh if you're a
player who wants to find secrets you can
use the area scanning equipment um
dexterity is one of my favorites i think
hugo's too like because we really like
to play the game fast so this is also up
to kyrie's level through level yeah
absolutely yeah and uh and here's here's
our runes all right um another another
area that you can really change the way
you play uh hugo is going to set it up
so that he actually plays faster um so
you could see he equipped here the
savagery roon and the blood
the savagery rune lets him do glory
kills even faster um and the blood field
when you do a glory kill it gives you a
speed boost so you just are zipping
through the environment at you know
almost uncontrollable speeds sometimes
do the runes unlock are they pick up so
they're down on my feet you actually you
you find these um kind of hellish
tablets uh throughout the game um and
those open up challenges that you you
they kind of take you to a whole
different different experience almost
like these little arcade experiences
that you uh some of them are about
moving fast some of them are about um
you know killing enemies in a certain
amount of time all different types
blowing up barrels all different types
of little kind of like arcadey
challenges
to resolve any questions or concerns so
this part i mean lazarus is a pretty
loaded loaded term where what's going on
here is this some sort of religious non
it is we i mean we've kind of with the
uac we've kind of merged religion and
science
um
and
like the cult uh
so uh it's it's
uh
you really do get this like they were
really pretty bizarre in what they did
and as you and as you pick up codex
entries again you know like we really do
try to keep the keep the story um very
environmental um you pick up things as
you as you play through the game um kind
of see little nods to to things that
they were doing um are there any emails
from nigerian businessmen
no emails
but we do have a codex uh that that you
um
is that a pinky is that what they look
like yeah whoa okay they're bipedal
again yep
yeah again very inspired but totally new
oh
did you just rip its butt out
it ripped its tail up
i was i was not expecting to see one
actually i was looking forward to seeing
it because the the the redesigned pinky
and doom three i remember was
was really something else yeah
so there's there's the pinky he's he's
he's awesome and even here we we uh you
you can find uh uh these little data
pads throughout they give you give you
lore on all the demons and the the
different characters the website stories
little back stories about each
motivation yeah and and it's all you
know it's all for the player that just
wants to blast through and play fast and
do a you know do an awesome you know uh
stream or or wants to do a speed run
it's it's it's it's out of their way but
uh but for the player who really wants
more information on all the stuff it's
it's really there yeah that must be a
difficult thing to marry trying to like
appeal to
the sort of doomed purists and then you
know obviously especially with the
multiplayer you guys
you're making you know you're nodding
towards new generations you know what i
mean like i was i was young when doom
came out i'm 30 now so like it was a
long long time ago yeah for sure yeah
and it is uh you know even just like
this like multiple ways into into spaces
like that way if you you kind of look
around and you explore you actually get
a mega health which is is i mean it's a
massive massive upgrade
um but yeah uh really really trying to
uh you know i said while we were talking
before the show um you know trying to
trying to find that balance for
um you know if you've if you've never
played doom before you come in and
you're like and this is this is fun this
is awesome this isn't like something
i've i'm i'm playing right now it's it's
it's fast and it i'm dodging projectiles
not reloading my gun you know things
like this revenant just
he looks crazy
he's this giant skeleton with a jet pack
and a rocket launcher on his shoulder
when you go into the inventory does it
like slow it down it's like quarter
speed or something as well yeah it's
like walking
yeah it goes into a bit of a slow mode
um so that you get your chance but the
thing is is like you don't um you don't
have to you don't have to hold long
enough to go into slow-mo so once you
learn the placements of your guns you
can actually quick flip um
and uh and and switch to any gun just as
if you you are like no slow down
whatsoever so like there hugo swapped
between uh two guns um uh that are those
two actually happen to be next to each
other on the wheel but you can you can
swap from any gun to any other gun um
and uh and it doesn't slow it down at
all and then changing mods uh if he
wanted to change to say the uh the
triple burst mod um he could do that in
a in a single button press and it would
it would put a quick change there
did you guys go double wielding on any
of these bad boys no no double wielding
uh it's all it's almost enough to manage
with like the the whole weapon yeah i
was kind of about to say you've got a
lot of systems kind of uh happening here
with the mods in one line
uh yeah what was the evidence of doing
the mods because like obviously doom
guns that was always a big thing you
know so you put in a bunch of guns how
many are in this 20 or so there's well
there's there's eight core guns uh eight
core guns plus the plus the bftg and the
chainsaw um and there's actually it's
kind of interesting how we change how we
handle those i'll talk about that um but
uh uh yeah so eight core guns and then a
bunch of them have uh you know a couple
mods to them um so you end up with uh
with a lot of combinations that you have
uh that you have access to and the mods
um really came out of you know wanting
additional functionality for the guns
but um also wanting to keep the
wheel very manageable and very fast
um so especially on console analyzing
that's probably more of a problem yeah
but even even on the pc i mean it's
honestly the the kind of uh the impetus
for the weapon wheel and being able to
to go from any weapon to any weapon
really really fast it comes from playing
on the pc you know that's when you're
when you're carrying eight or nine or
ten guns uh you know we've all played
you know quick three years
honestly in any of our games um and on
the pc you just it's it's awesome just
to be able to reach up and hit that it's
that thing or you know i
played thousands of hours a quick three
and i i bind the weapons i like to keys
right around wsad right um so the
grenade launcher is nowhere to be seen
yeah it's like i'm going railgun and
lightning gun right you know right under
my fingers um
and and that's kind of the idea behind
the weapon wheel from uh from a console
perspective and even from a pc
perspective works very similarly um is
that you have that immediacy of getting
to any gun uh just in one fast movement
and it works great with the mouse and
keyboard as well i mean we really
designed it uh taking taking you know
all platforms into account
uh speaking of mods the you know
actually bizarrely in recent years with
brutal doing we've seen doom kind of get
its own little resurgence uh how are you
guys gonna be sort of dealing with mods
on the pc version are you are you
allowing people to do them are you
supporting them
so we
basically we have a whole a whole
component that we built called snapmap
that that really is is it's it's trying
to take mods and open them up to
just about everybody we spent a ton of
time
working
you know working a lot on that making
that as
you know as robust as as we possibly can
giving people a massive opportunity we
just did a stream recently that showed
kind of the capabilities there and and
even then we're still just kind of
scratching the surface of what's capable
um and then our plan is honestly to to
kind of see how things go with that
listen to the community see see what uh
how we might move forward
kind of in concert with with uh um with
snapmap um and uh and and go from there
um so so we're really you know we're
hoping people do some
and honestly traditional modders are
some of the the ones that do the do the
coolest stuff with uh with snapmap right
out of the gates um it's not
specifically it's like level i've seen
some of the videos of it yeah obviously
over the past year or so that's
specifically like level design stuff
yeah you you can basically there's a ton
of modules that you basically can
configure in multiple ways you can
customize them um but the power of it is
really in um the the logic and and
that's kind of connecting uh different
components to other components it's it's
it's it's kind it's a bit of a like an
erector set for
for building uh gameplay and and game
levels is it just multiplayer is it also
a single player can you uh you can make
single player you can you can uh it's
it's two to four player co-op or
multiplayer um uh out of the box and uh
you know we're gonna be just like i said
i mean we're gonna be listening to to
what people do what they like about it
what they you know different things that
they want and uh and have already said
that you know all of our all of our
updates uh for for snapmap are free so
we're gonna just give people more and
more ways to to to use that and do uh do
really cool things but you can i mean
you literally can
create almost any game mode that you
want in snapmap just
just using the the logic
that's super shotgun yeah the super
shotgun is awesome it's it's it's
probably my favorite gun in
in the campaign
this is uh
actually where uh one of our one of our
room trials that gives you a uh um
gives you a rune is in a secret so you
kind of you see it behind the space bar
and all the room all the walls yeah yeah
most of them are most of them are
highlighted but some of the some of the
secret ones you kind of have to have to
look for so that's actually with this uh
that you see this thing you kind of come
up to it you can touch it i wouldn't
touch that it gives you
it's green it's green's good um and it
gives you a little uh a good sense of uh
of what you can do and and and what the
challenge is what you get you get the
rich get richer mod um we're not gonna
we're not gonna dive into that but uh
but it is it's uh
that spawns in sort of a different
instance somewhere yeah yeah you you
basically touch that and that takes you
to uh this this challenge mode so we're
gonna jump ahead again um and uh and go
to hell great great which is awesome go
to hell go to guests here on a show and
you're telling me to go to hell we fight
like hell now we're gonna go to hell um
hell's a tough one right because in
again it's it's like the the half-life
zen problem it's like you know sometimes
when you shift focus away from what the
core of the game is you can sort of lose
focus um what's been like developing
hell what what have you sort of
where is it similar to the sort of the
bases on mars and where is it different
you know i think um
it's been fun it's it's actually one of
them because it's so
so open-ended um it gives us really
opportunities to do lots of different
things both visually and from a gameplay
perspective um it's it's uh
you know visually hugo could talk about
kind of the the process we went through
in in in pulling it together but from a
gameplay per space a gameplay
perspective um i think you know when we
talk about
starting with gameplay when when we
build a level we start with blockouts
you know we just make gray shapes and
and make it work like is it fun to move
through this space or is there a line of
sight blockers that you can kind of
swing behind and and kind of get your
bearings again is there space for the
enemies to move through so it's a very
very abstract way to approach uh
um
a space like it doesn't it doesn't in
the in the earliest phases it doesn't
make any sense the way it looks um and
then a lot of times you know it's it's
like it's up to our artists to figure
out how does that space make sense from
a uac logistical perspective like what
is this space are these boxes are they
you know is it a conveyor belt or or
whatever um you've got less of a problem
with that that way less is a problem
it's liberating actually to a certain
extent the core of the gameplay is the
same but and it's actually a little bit
more forgiving to make the spaces uh the
health spaces just because kind of
anything goes because it's kind of a
crazy place floating rocks
you know so uh
and all the skulls and everything
everywhere so it it proved to be uh we
we could be a little bit more gamey with
those spaces too with more secrets more
hidden doors it's a little bit more
doomy i think the hell the hell maps are
probably the most doomed to have the
most doom feel to them
uh it it's it's fun plus i think the the
the feedback we've gotten has been
really positive people when they test
the game they love going to hell
gear up awesome um
how much of the game takes place in in
hell it was kind of like an afterthought
in doom three it was like the last
couple of levels uh how much of doing
without i don't get too much adorable
substantial amount it's probably um
maybe
a third okay so um yeah and and you
actually maybe a little more than a
third uh you you kind of go back and
forth okay um so
yeah doom three it it it kind of
pushed towards the end of the game
epilogue almost kind of felt like yeah
uh i always liked in doom three how it
how it kind of uh i thought our artist
at the time and and uh you know
tim managing that one was it i i loved
how you you kind of played through the
uac and it just got weirder and weirder
and more torn apart and kind of more of
that growth that kind of came through
um this one we use kind of the idea of
getting pulled kind of ripped both
from you know from the uac facilities
and and using portaling to to get there
and so you do end up going back and
forth a few times and and you know and
it worked well i mean it's the the game
is about combat uh and and so it's it's
you know you're you are you are shooting
and you are fighting a lot um so we
really uh we use that as a way to kind
of break things up and and allow you to
to kind of have these really diverse
visual experiences
i guess one of the things about showing
a game be as you know on a live stream
here you're going to a website and then
trying to demo the game or the trade
show or even to like your fans and then
also with trailers is that you want to
sort of show the the bombast you want to
show the like i don't know the the power
of the player it's like to murder all
these things yeah and
doomed to a lot of people is a game
that's it's quite oppressive it's not
really a power fantasy it's a game where
you're actually on the back foot and
you're trying to like scramble for life
um is there a way to like
on the higher difficulties is this game
approaching now obviously you don't want
to come to gamespot and put it on super
hard and then be dying over and over
again absolutely but the people who kind
of
like that type of uh difficulty like i'd
definitely be in that bracket yes can
you play doom in that sort of way you
can play it in a way that will
make you insane uh like as far as how
how hard it is um and it's it's super
fun i mean it's it's really fun to play
that way uh and it's it's honestly fun
to kind of bounce back and forth like to
play through on it really hard really
challenging you um and then when you
just want to kind of like chill and and
just be like i'm just going to sit back
and like
flow through and and just you know we
always call it like being your own fight
choreographer or or you know you guys
use the term like bruce lee on a
skateboard shotgun
that's caught caught a lot of attention
but that's kind of how it feels
sometimes particularly when you play it
on on an easier difficulty because you
can just kind of like flow through it
um
yeah here you basically jump down an
ancient demon skull's throat gray into
the into the bowels of hell
um but yeah the the difficulties uh
hugo is playing it on uh kind of the the
default um which is uh hurt me plenty um
but uh but there is there is a there is
a skill level uh that's easier than this
uh and and many that are harder and
several that are harder those kakadinas
look nasty yeah
um
one of our you know our upper end of the
difficulty scale is is nightmare mode
and then ultra nightmare mode uh ultra
nightmare being almost sadistic and it's
uh
you basically have to complete the game
um without dying oh no there's no
there's no checkpoints roguelike doom
yes it's uh it's it's really really
intense um and it's it's playing at
nightmare difficulty but just not not
being able to die um
so uh so and and honestly when people do
that they
they really they they love it it's it's
it's hard uh it's it's actually cool too
because you um when you when you die um
you uh oh bad mod switch there um
when you uh when you die it drops a a
helmet a doom marine helmet in the world
uh and your friends will see those
and you'll see them so you can always
try and get a little bit further than uh
then you see that collection of helmets
on the floor early in the game yeah
i like it a little bit of dark souls
kind of in there yeah messages almost
and your name's above it so it's kind of
neat
uh yeah are you guys doing anything else
then in terms of i mean you have these
little instanced areas these challenges
is there any leaderboards connected to
that stuff or no no need running or any
of that yeah not not really i mean i
think most of that will i mean my my
feelings like a lot of that ends up
happening on on uh nvidia's honestly
right people people streaming and
wanting it up on uh up on youtube and
angry
uh he's the same one yeah but there are
modifiers of those guys too yeah we
actually we have spectres as well if you
remember from uh yeah that's that right
there's a great strategy on him missed
the shot
um those guys are are uh their tails are
kind of like their weak spot so um
attack its weak point for massive damage
yeah exactly so uh
the mancubistas have weak weak points
too like sort of the fleshy parts
the aim for that most of the times you
aim for the heads on the enemies you'll
take them out a lot faster so when you
when you play on the harder difficulties
you definitely want to just focus on the
heads
as much as you can because it it kind of
comes down to
uh burn down rates at that point where
you just want to get them out of there
as fast as possible because they start
to
flank you and once they corner you they
kind of tell you to pieces yeah i mean
at least the hell night has it got a big
sort of white skull
to aim at there yeah we try to yeah we
try to give you a nice little
i'm gonna if there's anyone else in the
chat who wants to have any questions by
the way i'm keeping an eye i just wanted
to sort of show off the game as much as
possible uh before getting into that but
uh i'm gonna keep a little eye on it
here if anyone wants to ask the guys
some questions
we have at that thing
yeah those are our
uh all of those do you
slam a elevator menu pad at the end of
any level to compete
yeah
really
yeah
pretty much any time our doom marine
does anything it's very aggressive okay
he like
he touches a few buttons but uh but most
of the time he's punching stuff and uh
and ripping things apart
a bunch of people in the chat i mean the
bfg is a super popular weapon everyone's
asking for you don't have it in this
part of the
the the game by any chance here i do
yeah you do actually but i only have a
couple of shots you see the three chips
on the bottom below my ammo that tells
me how much gas i have for the uh
chainsaw it tells me how much gas i have
um ammo i have for the bfg okay
it's kind of your your uh
your weapon your nuclear weapons so you
don't want to fire off the nukes
we'll definitely uh we'll definitely
show the news awesome appreciate it it's
actually um
uh
we uh you might have noticed
when we pulled up the weapon wheel that
uh if you've seen it
in these later levels uh this is this is
a bad idea yeah
right into the back of it
um nice
uh
the uh the the
the chainsaw and the bfg actually aren't
on the weapon wheel uh on the right on
the controller we made them specific
face buttons and on uh on the on the uh
uh pc
specific keys right um like special use
cases i guess yeah and uh and really
that was the that was because they're
just they're the
they're these kind of oh my gosh um
they're these things that that you just
want to get to immediately you know like
when you when it's time to use the bfg
you're usually in a panic moment and you
just got a clear house so we didn't want
you having to kind of fumble around it's
just like one one quick key that you
could press that's close to your you
know close to your left hand or right
under your fingers on a controller um
and you can you can pull it out
uh joe x213 is asking uh one of the
questions about the customization i
guess of the ui and stuff can you change
elements like the crosshairs as well oh
yeah yeah you can go with a simplified
crosshair that's basically just like a
dot um and uh you can all of the ui
again you can you can play completely
stripped down no hud no compass no glory
kill no objective notifications uh all
of that crosshair style you can see he's
got her own default but it's simplified
also um
and that's fun i mean it's it's actually
it's
there's a there's a thrill to playing
there's a thrill to playing the game
with
no ammo indicators or health and rights
yeah because you're just like i i don't
know where i stand you kind of you kind
of have to watch the edges of your
screen and see if you're bleeding or if
you're in pain
let's go to the mess wheel and see what
comes up yeah exactly
um do you guys have any sort of system
requirements for this on pc i mean we're
playing on playstation 4 and it actually
looks pretty nice like frame rates real
good as well what are you looking at in
peace i'm guessing it's going to look
pretty good on pc but what are the sort
of minimums absolutely you know i i
should know this off top my head we just
released them so people go to i don't
want to kind of misquote them uh if
people we just released an article on on
bethesda net uh that that has our whole
pc uh system requirements and a list of
uh of uh specialized um custom features
on the on the pc that allow people to to
really go crazy with customizing their
their experience and customizing the
visuals um
uh
tutorials are popping up again yeah um
the uh uh so yeah so
and and we're actually working on a few
things um that we're we're hoping even
expand that that minimum pc spec uh
a bit so um mary kiss just posted them
in the twitch chat actually so if you're
watching this on twitch awesome should
be able to get them in there um
and and honestly on pc it looks amazing
this we we traveled here from dallas and
and uh so it's easier to throw a ps3 in
the backpack than a than a big computer
rig yeah um but uh
we uh
it's uh it
the the capabilities on the pc we uh our
tech team um you know some of our guys
like robert and thiago and and john and
billy uh you know
their their pride is is uh is
on on the pc i mean they just we're just
we're still pushing on the pc uh really
hard so it's i think i think people will
be really pleased i like that that
making the rocket from behind yeah weak
spot it is there's a lot of yeah there's
a lot of little strategies like that
that you can do to
kind of burn down these guys faster
i like it yeah are we approaching one of
the last engagements of this uh
demo yeah yeah okay awesome when we get
into that let's uh let's just let it
breathe again yeah we can we can watch
this all right
i didn't even mention it he actually got
double dumped so you'll see
about a quarter of the way into the game
you actually get get the double jump
kick it really so he's gonna continue
i think people want to see
it's kind of a strategy because when you
you know the first time you play this in
order to survive you definitely have to
take advantage of some of the things
that the
level designers have put in the world
for you right so being that i already
know like kind of what's gonna happen
it's almost like yeah wave based sort of
games where you're
taking you're not using too much of your
yeah because if you use that quad way
too early you're not gonna
he's a hell of a white hood
uh any spiders with uh
um mechanical legs i can't tell you
everything
come on you guys have been very good
about answering all these questions
you can take a pass on that
that was one of the things we actually
took a lot from rage was like you saw
the man could just jump down there
you've seen him all up controllers like
rage did a great job with enemies moving
through the environment in really cool
ways i think yeah those standard enemies
the
what were they sort of zombie
type yeah
mutants or yeah i mean they were
different
guys but um yeah they oh my god
six oh
my god
look at that vfg right as he pulled it
out there goes your
heart
oh he's beating you
you are going to hear about that for a
while
okay so poor hugo all right we're go
we'll jump back in and show the bfg we
cannot not jump
angry
well now
now i'm not messing around these people
are going down yeah all right yeah
exactly no more demo
just like straight ahead i have to
repeat
myself that was ridiculous
okay oh we don't mind we're we're not
going anywhere you can do all this again
if you want
now it's perfect you just let me know if
you want me to play
i did it the last time there was there
was a
there was good drama that time i died
fine line isn't it trying to keep that
drama with that
the micro missile mod that he has here
is really fun too it's like
they're kind of like these homing homing
missiles um and they stick and then
explode so you get like this kind of
combinatorial damage that it's really
fun
right there he's using i haven't even
talked about it he's using uh grenades
they recharge you can upgrade your
equipment um to recharge faster to have
multiples um
and there's a there's a few pieces of
equipment in the game you can use
frag grenades uh
or
what we call siphon grenades
that actually draw uh they do damage to
to enemies to demons and they give that
give you a health boost
kind of give that back to you
and then there's a there's a decoy
that's pretty fun because you can you
can kind of drop a decoy and uh and the
enemies react to it and kind of start to
attack it and it gives you an
opportunity to kind of take a different
position on them
and you can flip through those uh really
really fast as well you kind of carry
them with you
oh my gosh
all right yeah let's give hugo some some
quiet time here see if we can
we can pull it out of the bag
here we go
he's super
and obviously it's the bfg so it took
him out but yeah it will take out
multiples
oh there you go
don't matter if you hit him yep it's got
the
energy
kind of a room cleaner
excellent
usually like you know
obviously
after i've uh finished to sort of clean
the room make sure you get everything
you need
it's important check for scenes
yeah that's kind of the too like because
there's just i'm not exposing too many
of them but there's secrets everywhere
so right i feel i feel guilty we've
already exposed so many
but there is one
what yeah collectible little doom guys
yeah wow in in all different
so you're rewarded to like if you want
to you could blast through the game that
was the keem guy actually so he's
commander you're getting kidding he's
the doom guy seemed like commander keane
oh wow and then you go into your uh you
go into kind of your uh
like where you where you choose to
resume your your campaign
uh you go in there and there's a uh
there's a viewer where you can see the
ones you picked up and each one unlocks
uh one of our one of our creatures or
our uh our guns in our model viewer
right so you can go in and spin it
around and look at it really close
really take time to to see the detail in
the in the world is there a command to
keen skin from multiplayer
there's not a commander king skin put it
on that would be awesome that it's it's
on the backlog already right now yeah
freaking what do you call that thing you
jumped up pogo stick and all yeah
beans with big and make a rocket
so you expect people to sort of clear
out areas and then to sort of be looking
a bit for the it's kind of a little bit
of both i mean there's uh
you know there's there's spaces in
between the major fights where there's
lots of secrets or secrets inside some
of the major fights so like there's some
in here
some of them are not uh revealed in in
in the auto map those are like the super
secrets
um
and then most of them are
so there's there's definitely one here
you see a door and it's red clearly at
some point that will open for you if you
sometimes that's part of the the main
sort of progression of the game
sometimes it's uh
it's more of a secret
so doubling back checking things
and even with that you know if you're if
you're really into secrets you really
want to find them uh you can you can
upgrade your suit to give you these
capabilities he actually he kind of has
on there um
one thing we didn't really talk about is
uh like if you go back to your there's
another another collectible
um
is there any like i don't know why i
didn't pick them up but uh so that one
unlocks the cyber demon model that was
the silver guy but pull up your pull up
your um menu again uh the the
map
uh so you can see the challenges there
and the exploration like on this map
there's six secrets that you can find
he's found just two of them um the the
kind of orange uh triangles with the
circles around them those are your
currency for upgrading your guns so you
get in this case you get you get
currency for just regular combat you get
uh upgrade upgrade currency for these
challenges each mode or each map has uh
has several challenges that you can
combat challenges that you can uh you
can get and then you get them for
exploration so you could earn two uh
upgrades just for finding secrets so
lots of different ways to you know if
you if you want to upgrade your guns and
get uh you know
make that progression but you you're
kind of more into the exploration um you
know you'll get upgrades just for combat
but uh but if you don't want to do the
challenges you can get it through it
through exploration and then and you
know oh geez
the harder difficult like the you know
the higher up in difficulty you go the
more that stuff really comes into play
yeah yeah cause like if you know the the
way i'm playing now and hurt me plenty i
don't really have to upgrade anything i
could probably beat the game you know
without upgrading the weapons and and we
want to provide the user without
experience but like when you start going
up in difficulties the mastery of the
guns in particular and the runes become
super important because mastery like one
of the masters for the shotgun for
example is a double tap so there is no
reload i get two shotguns yeah so it's i
mean it's devastatingly powerful but
you're playing on nightmare or nightmare
in the final level of the game where
you're you're because the higher up in
difficulty you go the more aggressive
the enemies are they throw more they
throw more their heavy heavy shots at
you so you're definitely going to need
uh a little bit more of that stuff
you got that skull yeah i got the skull
but um
is there any narrative reason why
there's all these little
funko pop doom dudes around it's just
just cool yeah that's cool the the
nature of the game is it just kind of
doesn't take itself too seriously like
the narrative stuff you know like it's
it's all kind of tongue in cheeky a
little bit and just for fun and so
we thought if he's going to pick up
anything he's going to pick up little
doomguy dolls yeah and and uh you know
just yeah it just seemed amusing to us
and fun so why not it's kind of one of
those things like it's in the secrets it
doesn't
you know it doesn't have to maintain a
huge amount of question it's just it's
kind of like it you want to get to those
things where you where you find it and
you're like oh that's awesome so yeah
one thing we talked about uh
was just like the the codex is actually
pretty cool because like you could uh
you pick up data files and you can
uncover
a lot of the lore of the game then the
narrative is pretty much out of your way
you don't have to experience it i mean i
kind of hammed it up a little bit and
stopped and listened to some of the
audio files for the people watching
online but if you've done it before you
could just rip right past it and um you
know through digging the corners and and
and checking out picking up data files
you could pretty much put together like
what happened at the uac uh you know
maybe a little bit about who you are and
how you got there and uh but we kind of
did it in a way that we want the player
to kind of piece it together the story
it's it's heavy on the lore
and it's it's sort of oblique and and uh
we felt like that was
the right kind of story to tell for this
game yeah i mean it seems like you have
done a
you it seems like you guys are very
aware of the different masters you were
serving with this game oh yeah or the
different audiences that want it there
are there's the people who are super
super into doom and then there are the
people who just want to blaze through it
really quickly i mean
across the board you have the same
problem to multiplayer i guess where
you're like you want to make something
that's progressive in some way but also
harpin's back
how does that how does it feel now being
so close to release because surely the
best thing to be would
for people to play it and sort of take
the game on its own terms that's it and
and if i had one if i had one wish it's
that uh or one hope it's that people
people just play it you know they they
you know if they go out and buy it they
go out and buy it if they play it at a
friend's house they play it at a
friend's house and uh uh or or however
you rent it however you play games um
uh i i just want people to play it
honestly be and and and kind of make up
their own mind uh they they uh uh
because it it
it's it's one of those games that to
watch it is it's fun like i hope people
have have enjoyed watching it and kind
of get a sense of of what it's like um
but uh you know but like a good game
there's nothing like playing it there's
nothing like feeling how it how it what
it feels like to play um it's it's um
it's one of the you know it's rare that
you actually work on a game and after
three years and playing it for hundreds
and hundreds of hours that you sit down
and you really enjoy playing it right um
i'm i i've said it before like he gets
to play but i'm kind of jealous because
i want to be the one playing it because
it's a because it's fun but you just
there's just a uh
there's just a
thrill to trying to to make it look
great and and having that that fun with
it um that it's just it's it's it's cool
i mean we we everybody in internally um
you know
we are that audience you know like right
you talk about that that broad audience
just internally we have you know we have
guys who are everywhere from
20 years old to you know 50 years old 55
years old um that has every
different experience with doom that you
can imagine so um so
we've kind of been our own audience to
begin with and and made decisions uh a
lot around
you know making us making our own our
own group happy with the game so i mean
you need to be your biggest critics you
do yeah especially a game like doom
especially within it yeah like it's not
you're basically taking the prized
possession of of the company and putting
it out there again so yeah yeah big
responsibility yeah absolutely and we
take it we take it very seriously it's
it's been a blast it's a lot of fun a
lot of work um but uh you know but i i
think um
i i think when you when you play it i
think i think people who have spent a
lot of time with doom over the years
will be like this feels like a doom game
we get that a lot when we have focus
testers come in and play it or whatever
it's like this really feels like doom um
and hopefully for for new players who
have never tried a doom game this this
is this is kind of the the first of of
of their history with with the game yeah
uh rather anecdotally i was i was quite
skeptical about myself especially from
like seeing some of the trailers the
pace the sort of the power fantasy
element of it um and when i played the
multiplayer beta
it was that thing where i was like oh i
know the game i'm playing now yeah and
i'm enjoying it yeah um and it's a sort
of a similar experience watching single
player watching it as we have now for
like an hour where it's very very
different when you're watching these
like truncated edited versions of
something and then you're actually
seeing the patient like oh okay it
actually kind of reminds me of
wolfenstein and that line was like oh
that's the game that's being made yeah
and that game turned out to be pretty
yeah great and hugo is doing a good job
of making it like again we've played the
game a lot so uh you know when players
get in we try to we try to ramp them up
but uh the the the feel of of campaign
the the pace of it um it's it's kind of
like watching a sport somebody who does
it does it really well they make it look
they make it look like uh like okay
that's me i mean when he's not getting
beaten to death yeah
he did die i guess that's that's true
and that was on the default difficulty
um
uh but it is it is it's a completely
different experience to sit and and have
the controller keyboard mouse in your
hands and and uh and just and just feel
it and then again when you like on the
pc you know we we you run unlocked frame
rate uh you know up to like 140 frames a
second or 150 frames a second and a
wider fov and you know kind of have
tweaked it it's it's like
i mean
it's it's shocking it's shocking how
fast it goes it's just in it's
unbelievable yeah it does it even feels
faster on the on
good stuff all right may 13th of this
year only weeks away my goodness uh
marty stratton hugo martin thank you so
much for coming in thank you um any
final thoughts on this do you have any
more sort of
for people who don't have access to the
game between now and the second week of
may we're going to get more information
on doom will he be teasing out more
stuff yeah absolutely we'll be we've got
we've got
more videos coming we've got a lot more
information we've got a whole kind of
technical feature uh that we're doing uh
best place to go is to bethesda.net and
um and they can they'll get a good look
at everything we're doing cool awesome
thank you both so much for coming in all
right thank you very much your time
really appreciate it no worries thanks
for watching last piece of housekeeping
by the way i'm pretty sure we still
haven't given these away i actually
don't know but why not hit that rt
button follow us on
at
gamespot
on the twitters you can win this hot
cyberdemon funko pop games doom number
91 out of tier collection of funko pops
if you don't win that we have a bunch of
other little prizes as well to give out
thank you so much for watching today's
stream as ever hit that follow button if
you're watching on twitch if you're
watching on gamespot we love you loads
if you're watching this on facebook
apparently we're streaming this on
facebook that's a thing right now uh get
off your facebook thing go
stop being on your mobile stream go live
life but also thank you so much and
maybe hit a button that says followers i
don't know i don't stream on facebook uh
thanks so much to mary kushner today for
running the stream uh and we will see
you next time on gamespot now playing
adios
you